une autre tragédie vraiment qui a frappé
le sri lanka en ce dimanche de pâques
imaginez on parle d'une vente
coordonnées d'attentats contre des
hôtels de luxe et des église remplie qui
ont fait là jusqu'à présent 207 morts on
parle de dizaines d'étrangers 450
blessés
aussi on avec nous mark bradley qui est
chercheur au centre d'études et de
recherches sur l'inde et l'asie du sud à
l'uqam la première chose monsieur
bradley qui frappe c'est vraiment
l'extrême violence de ces attaques l'an
qui étaient coordonnées oui c'est ce qui
surprend surtout parce que c'est un pays
qui a connu énormément de violence au
cours des trente dernières années d'une
guerre civile qui s'est terminée
officiellement il y a dix ans on va
fêter le 10e anniversaire du retour de
la paix là dans quelques semaines mais
on n'a jamais vu une série d' attaque
d'abord russie nombreuses et en
plusieurs lieux différents père de trois
villes et on parle de plusieurs hôtel de
5 étoiles
c'est ça c'est tout à fait inusitée on
n'est pas en mesure de comprendre pour
le moment comme vous le disiez on avait
l'impression que dès qu'on assiste à une
certaine accalmie comme vous le disiez
là où sri lanka alors est-ce que c'est
annonciateur de la reprise de violences
là bas c'est difficile à dire vous savez
le sri lanka est un pays magnifique
c'est une île qui est à peu près du même
superficie que le nouveau brunswick et
qui comporte une vingtaine de millions
22 millions de personnes essentiellement
de deux cultures deux peuples différents
les tamouls et les cinghalais et les
cinghalais sont essentiellement
bouddhiste 95% et les tamouls de son
ouïe hindous ou chrétiens ou musulmans
ou athée mais ils forment la minorité et
il ya eu pendant des siècles des
royaumes différent sur cette île jusqu'à
ce que les anglais les coloniaux arrive
et installe un système unifié en faisant
tomber tous les petits royaumes et en
fédérant tous et tous ces petits états
et puis au départ les anglais ont quitté
ils ont laissé le pays se débrouiller
tout seul et de fils d'un noble
toutes sortes de violences entre les
minorités les majorités la majorité les
minorités et malheureusement ce qui
arrive aujourd'hui semble vouloir
annoncer un retour à la violence
exactement lorsqu'on voit lorsqu'on
décortique ces attaques là aujourd'hui
ce sont des hôtels de luxe qui sont
visés également la minorité chrétienne
évidemment qu'est ce qu'on peut
comprendre du message qui est lancée par
les gens qui ont perpétré ces attaques
c'est extrêmement difficile on sait
aussi c'est clair c'est les chrétiens
qui était visé et pas seulement les
catholiques la majorité catholique chez
les chrétiens cela survient en plein
dimanche départ à plus mais il ya aussi
les églises évangéliques sur la côte est
bâti cas là aussi ce sont 7 une église
évangélique été attaqués donc les
chrétiens de plusieurs parce qu'il ya
plusieurs dénominations chrétiennes ou
celle en cas c'est un pays qui est
extrêmement religieux il ya des chiites
et des sunnites de différentes
obédiences pour les musulmans enfin vous
voyez c'est extrêmement diversifiée là
c'est clair que c'était le jour de
pâques pour les chrétiens et les gros
hôtels faisaient des les brunchs du
dimanche là pour lui pour nous à
minorité riche qui pouvaient recevoir le
plaisir de l'art le couvert pour ça
c'est la première fois qu'on a vraiment
visé la minorité puisqu'on parle d'un
pape à peine 2 millions de personnes sur
sur 22 millions
les chrétiens pourquoi c'est encore à
définir
parce que pour le moment monsieur
bradley on n'a pas encore revendiqué
cette attaque lundi la personne qui l'a
revendiquée
non pas pour le moment mais il ya plein
de gens qui n'hésitent pas à pointer du
doigt ici et là ce avait la paix fait la
guerre s'est terminée en 2009 mais la
paix n'est pas jamais revenue totalement
et ça prend pas grand chose pour que la
poudrière explose à nouveau ce qui fait
que l'on voit sur les réseaux sociaux
jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient fermés
temporairement perdu c'est la nuit
actuellement sri lanka donc on a fermé
tout ça mais il ya des tas de gens qui
réussissent à lancer des suppositions
des accusations et
a peut être très dangereux peau pour des
tas de gens qui n'ont rien avoir avec
soi mais qui pourrait se faire accuser
le bilan et thérèse important même plus
grand que christchurch en parlent d'eux
mêmes 207 noir est ce qu'il pourrait y
avoir une forme de récupération
politique de cet attentat la csu c'est
sûr puisque on est en année électorale
l'année qui vient de se terminer en 2018
a vu le président essayer d'installer un
nouveau premier ministre parle de
manipulation antidémocratique
ça fait tout un on a eu une période où
il y avait deux premiers ministres qui
s'excluent est l'un l'autre
les élections sont prévues pour le
président à janvier prochain mais d'ici
là il peut se passer des tas de choses
et il ya des gens qui passent d'un parti
à l'hôtel les grimaces et c'est un pays
encore du tir man 2 ça veut pas dire que
c'est mal en soi mais la corruption si
elles existent ici aux etats-unis
imaginer comment ça peut exister dans un
petit pays comme le sri lanka alors ça
c'est facile de faire jouer les tables
j'ai envie de vous demander en terminant
qu'est ce qui vous surprend le plus de
ce qu'on a vu là bas dans les dernières
heures dans ces attentats
parce que vous semblez quand même sous
le choc de ce qui s'est pas fait oui
parce que cette population chrétienne a
été jusqu'à un certain point oublié vous
savez c'est les tamouls en fait parce
que les cinghalais la majorité c'est un
peuple une culture vous il n'ya pas
ailleurs qu'au sri lanka où il ya des
cinghalais c'est le seul pays au monde
où il ya des cinghalais des tamouls par
contre c'est un peu comme les kurdes où
les basques lits sont partout ce très
ancien de civilisation les tamouls mais
ils ont aucun pays eux comme les basques
ou comme les kurdes
il n'y a pas un pays kurde est pas un
pays bas ce n'est pas un pays tamoul
mais le foyer principal c'est le sud de
l'aisne et il ya mille ans c'était la
grande civilisation de l'océan indien
jusque en asie du sud-est jusqu'en
afrique orientale c'était les tamouls
qui menait donc au sri lanka c'est
normal on est à 65 km il y avait des
royaux tamouls il en voyant que st gall
et qui était essentiellement sur le mans
tant de l'île quand les anglais sont
revenus et qui sont partis ils ont tout
laissé en plan de ce groupe est amour
qu'est-ce qui vous marque vous de ce qui
s'est passé parce que longtemps accusé
les hindous tamoule hindoue c'est plus
le cas là on a accusé les musulmans
depuis les trois dernières années a eu
plusieurs attaques contre des musulmans
est là depuis quatre mois
c'est les églises chrétiennes qui sont
attaqués gétaz moule mais tamouls
indienne tamouls chrétien père voilà la
marque brad lidge est chercheur au
centre d'études et de recherches sur
l'inde et l'asie du sud merci d'avoir
été avec merci à vous